est-ce que vous savez comment on fait
pour être moins malade il faut trouver
soit des moyens d'éviter les maladies
soit des moyens de soigner les maladie
pour ça il faut des chercheuses et des
chercheurs et pour chercher ils ont
besoin de plein de trucs ils ont besoin
de temps ils ont besoin de matériel ils
ont besoin de labo donc d'argent du
temps des laboratoires et du matériel
ils peuvent en trouver à l'Institut
Pasteur là-bas il y a 1600 chercheuses
et chercheurs qui travaille sur les
maladies infectieuses les cancers les
maladies neurodégénératives comme
Alzheimer ou le Microb allez voir ma
dernière vidéo j'en parle donc de quoi
il a besoin l'Institut Pasteur pour nous
aider à être moins malade d'argent et
comme contrairement à ce qu'on croit
l'Institut Pasteur c'est pas un
organisme public payé par l'État c'est
une fondation privée bah un/ers de
l'argent qu'il a pour payer tout ça ça
vient de donateurs des particuliers et
des entreprises il y a d'un côté des
chercheurs qui cherchent et de l'autre
des donateurs qui donnent des
particuliers ou des entreprises donc si
vous voulez aider les gens qui cherchent
comment faire pour qu'on soit moins
malade bah rendez-vous sur pasteurdon.fr
vous donnez ce que vous pouvez merci